PROFESSOR: So now
let's synthesize
all of our models of aerosol
generation and dynamics
in a well-mixed indoor space
and epidemiological models
of spreading and transfer
of disease in that space
and formulate a safety
guideline for COVID-19
assuming indoor
airborne transmission
in a well-mixed room.
And so there's a number of
ways we could go about this.
And the approach that
I would like to propose
is that we require that the
indoor reproductive number is
less than some tolerance.
So this epsilon here
is the tolerance.
So typically something
might be a lot less
than 1 or maybe you get to
allow it to be closer to 1.
And so that is essentially
the probability
of a transmission
from one infector that
enters the room at t equals
0 and stays for a time
tau in the presence of a
total number of n people
in the room, which is the
occupancy of the room.
So obviously, this
doesn't handle
every possible situation.
It is possible, if there is
a very prevalent infection
rate in the community
that the room may
find several infectors entering
at once, in which case,
we could certainly
increase this number.
And then the 1 here
would be replaced by i0
as we've seen before.
On the other hand, if you're
interested in controlling
the spread of the
disease and you're not
worried about a specific person,
but you just want to say,
I would like to make
this room not contribute
to spreading of the disease--
and imagine if
everybody did that,
then no rooms would contribute
to spreading the disease--
so then this criteria would
say that if two infectors came,
they might infect two
people, or three infectors,
you're worried
about three people.
Well we want to make sure is
that the number of infectors
is not growing.
So in other words, if
there's one infector,
they don't infect another one.
So the fact that there
are more infectors
gives a chance of at
least some infection,
but this seems like a more
general and simpler criterion.
It's also a little bit like
when the fire department
looks at a room and
decides on occupancy
limit for an indoor space.
There's no fire going on.
They're not estimating what's
the probability of a fire.
It's a conditional probability.
They're saying,
if there's a fire,
we want to make sure
these people can get out.
And so they think about
where the fire might start,
where the smoke is,
where are exits,
and how many people
can realistically
get out of that room before
the fire and the smoke
reach a dangerous level.
So this indoor safety
guideline has a similar flavor,
where we're essentially defining
here the number of people
and also the amount of occupancy
time that would be allowable.
So that it'd be unlikely
for one infector
to create a new infection
and hence spread the disease.
So that is the basic thinking.
So this it's basically the
conditional probability
of spreading given this, that
an infector enters at times 0
and stays for a time t.
So that's basically how we
formulate the guideline.
And now let's think about--
already at this
level without getting
into the details of what goes
into beta, which we've already
talked about, there's a
very important concept here,
which is that if I define
beta with brackets here to be
the average transmission rate.
So the transmission rate
may be changing in time,
for example, as droplets
are building up in the room
as we've discussed.
But let's just think of kind of
an average transmission rate.
Then this integral in time
is just beta brackets,
beta average times tau.
So if I put the beta
bracket on the other side,
I arrive at a very
fundamental result,
which is that the number of
susceptibles in the room,
which is roughly the occupancy--
although, if you're
very low occupancy,
it's everybody but the infected
person, so it's n minus 1--
times the typical time spent in
the room by the infected person
is less than the
tolerance divided
by the average
transmission rate.
This is very simple
and very general
relationship, which does not
depend on the details of beta.
But what it's telling you is
something which already you
may recognize is very
different than any
of the existing official
safety guidelines.
Official safety guidelines
always limit one quantity.
For example, they might limit
the number of people in a room.
They also can get a limit such
as that from social distancing.
So you could take the
area of the room, divide
by a little six foot
radius around each person--
or a three foot
radius or a six foot
separation-- and
get at an occupancy.
So you fix n.
The problem with that is
that time has to play a role.
If a certain number
of people are
in a room for a very short
time, it's really unlikely
to have any transmission.
But if the same number
stays for a very long time,
eventually some transmission
must take place.
So time has to be important.
You will also find
limits on time.
The CDC defines a contact
where transmission
is possible as being within six
feet of an infectious person
for more than 15 minutes.
So there is a time
constraint there.
So it says that
after 15 minutes,
you should expect to be
potentially infected.
But the problem
is that that's not
accounting for transmission rate
factors, such as ventilation
and all the things
that we've discussed,
and also the occupancy.
So how many people could
you transmit it to?
If you're by yourself
in a room or there's
only two or three people
in a very large space,
are you really going to
transmit in 15 minutes?
Not necessarily.
And anyway, so
that is the problem
with those kinds of criteria.
And it can be easily seen by
plotting this relationship
here.
So by the way,
this quantity here,
which is the product of n
and t, or n minus one and t,
is what I like to call the
cumulative you exposure time.
So the time that you're exposed
to the infected individual,
tau, is multiplied by how many
other people are in the room
because that's how many
people could get infected.
So the more people that there
are, the more chance that one
of them could be infected
in a well-mixed room.
And so you really don't have
a bound just on time.
It's really this product
that's important.
And so let's plot what
this looks like now.
So if we have here the time
and here the occupancy,
then this guideline is a
bound that looks like this.
It saturates at one.
So basically, if you're
below this guideline here,
you're considered safe.
And up here is
potentially unsafe.
Meaning that given the
tolerance that you've chosen,
you would expect
that there could
be a transmission with
greater than that probability.
OK.
It saturates at one because
it will never go below one.
Because only one
person, you're not
going to transmit to anybody.
So it's OK.
So an occupancy of one is
OK, except in a building
where perhaps other
people have come and gone
from that room or ventilation
is bringing particles
from other rooms.
And we'll come back to that.
But just at the simple
level of analyzing one room,
obviously one is fine.
And here you see a very
fundamental problem
that I was just
alluding to, which
is that if I put the standard
guidelines on-- for example,
a limit on number of people.
So this could be
fixed occupancy.
And in fact, in Massachusetts,
for example, right now
there is a guideline which
says n is less than 25.
No more than 25 persons
can congregate in a room.
In fact, I'm teaching
class right now which
we have 51 people, and I was
able to split into two rooms.
And then this rule
came along, and then we
had to start doing three,
remotely broadcasting
between those rooms because
we have a 25 person rule.
The problem with that rule is it
doesn't take into account time.
What if my class is
only five minutes long?
Or let's say it's
one-hour long, OK.
In that time, if I don't have
an expectation transmission,
I should be OK.
On the other hand,
if those 20 people
sit in the classroom
for several weeks,
it's pretty likely that if an
infected person is among them,
there will be a transmission.
So time has to come in.
And that you see
very clearly here
from the crossing of the fixed
occupancy with the safety
guideline.
So for a short amount of
time, the fixed occupancy,
which is telling you
should be under this--
so basically you should
only have a lower occupancy.
So this is a fixed
occupancy bound.
For example, the one
in Massachusetts.
At first, this is
too conservative.
So you are telling people
they cannot be in the space,
but until this amount
of time has passed,
it's very unlikely that
anybody would transmit.
Imagine this time as one minute.
It's pretty unlikely that you're
going to have a transmission.
On the other hand,
if you keep waiting,
you always cross
the yellow line.
And over here it's too risky
and too dangerous, basically.
Because you're allowing
people to think that
they're safe because
there's only 25.
But let's say this crossover
happens after one hour,
and the people are in
the room for five hours,
there's a very high
risk of transmission.
So just putting out
a number like 25
doesn't really protect you
because these lines always
cross.
You will always cross the safety
guideline at a certain time.
That's the safe time.
OK.
Similarly, so basically-- so
let me just kind of stress that
here.
So this is basically, what
we're really concerned is this.
We're very concerned
about situations
where a guideline is giving
people the sense of protection,
and in fact they're
at high-risk.
We're also concerned
about this case here.
Because for example, as
in the case of my class,
we might be causing some
damage to people's education
or to their businesses
or to the economy
by shutting down a certain
space or imposing a limit that
doesn't have really a strong
scientific basis because we
don't expect
transmission to happen
under those circumstances.
So we're concerned about both.
But I'm particularly concerned
about the overly risky case
because that is contributing
to transmission of the disease,
and potentially loss of life.
Now, if we look in
the other direction,
we have the same kind of issue.
So if we have a time limit--
for example, let's say here.
You know, this
could be like this.
So this would be a fixed time.
For example, 15
minutes from the CDC
is the time they
recommend for contact.
So that's a pretty short time.
OK, and what a
guideline like that says
is that if you're
in the presence
of an infected person--
sufficiently close-- for 15
minutes, then here you're safe,
but over here you're unsafe.
But again, you have
the same phenomena.
Now, 15 minutes is
a pretty short time,
so that's typically
going to be safe.
But again, in this region
it's too conservative.
So the blue here is
still too conservative.
But now, when you get up
here, even the 15-minute rule
eventually becomes unsafe.
Because if there's a very
large amount people in a room
and they also can interact with
each other through well-mixed
space--
so I'm not talking about
a really, really big room.
I'm talking about
a small enough room
that you could expect air to be
transmitted between the people
in that space--
then if I keep
increasing occupancy,
again I cross that line.
There's always a crossing.
So you cannot have a guideline
only based on time or only
based on occupancy.
If you think of this
limit-- for example,
how about we take for
the 15-minute rule,
what if I put 15 people or maybe
20 people into a small tent--
just let's say a
little bit bigger
in the size of this board--
and everybody's
standing close together.
We might pass the infection in
much less time than 15 minutes
because we have a chance
to infect each other,
and if I keep going up, I'm
going to cross that line.
And the tent also has a very
small volume, poor ventilation,
and this yellow
curve is very low.
OK, so this concept
of the cumulative exposure time
is really important
to understand
because it's very general.
It really isn't so tied to
the details of the model.
And it just shows
you that any bound
on one parameter such
as occupancy, time,
and I should mention
also social distance.
Because that's the big one
which is happening right now.
Social distance
guidelines-- so this
would be that the distance,
d, is greater than six feet.
And that's a CDC guideline
in the United States.
It can be greater than one
meter, which is 3 feet,
and that's from the World
Health Organization.
So about half the distance.
That leads to a guideline
where there's still
a maximum occupancy, which is
the area of the room divided
by d squared, or by some
other factor depending
how you think people are
going to be arranged.
But basically, you go into the
room, you map out that spacing,
and you arrive at
a fixed occupancy.
This is being done
everywhere, including
here at MIT right now.
And that still leads
to fixed occupancy.
So regardless of
how it was derived,
you still have a
fixed occupancy,
which is too
conservative at first,
and eventually is too risky.
And you must know
where is that crossover
point because occupancy
and time are linked.